in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Brian
and Melissa are with us hey guys how are
you no do it
welcome welcome where do you live we are
from Fremont California I came out for
the entree leadership master series this
week all right have you had a good week
it was been it's been amazing
very cool we're honored to have you this
week what kind of business do you have
I run discover hope behavioral solutions
we work with kids with autism providing
in-home behavioral services Wow very
cool what a rewarding thing very cool
and while you're here you're gonna do a
debt free scream that's right I love it
I love it how much have you paid off we
paid off a hundred twenty-five thousand
four hundred dollars and how long did
that take it took us four years we had a
lot of life during that four years I
started the business we cash flow the
rest of Bryon's grad school and we had
two beautiful children cool Brian what's
your degree in special education good
for you good for you so your household
income range through that four years was
wife so with Brian being in school and
with starting the business there was a
big range so at the lowest we made 80
thousand a year and at the highest we
made about double that so about 160 okay
Wow and your kids ages and names om is a
little over two years old and Ella is
six months old Oh Oh little bitty ones
yes okay so what is your shirt say I see
Dave but that's all I can see from here
yeah you know there's some scissors
cutting up a credit card called the
American distress card yeah
and underneath that it says Dave is my
home boy very cool for those of you who
don't know I'm looking out of our window
from our studio across the lobby and
they are standing in Martha's place
which is our kitchen and and bookstore
area where we have homemade baked goods
and coffees and that kind of thing it
was far enough away I couldn't see all
of the deal on the t-shirt so very cool
well so you guys have done everything in
the world in four years I mean you live
life while I open here what do you what
do you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt while you mean you were
juggling everything and still pulled
this off
you know I think for me the secret was
committing first of all it was my
beautiful wife's Melissa's idea to go
through FPU and took a little convincing
once I bought into it
it got a lot easier other than that
though it's just to stay committed stay
steadfast that for us was really the key
once we were committed it was relatively
easy every time the wind comes at least
you know how to fight the storm
absolutely yeah and you had a lot of
different things come against you is
mathematically anyway we did and but you
know that commitment says okay we're
gonna we're gonna stay on the rails
we're gonna stay on the rails we're
staying forward not make much progress
this month we're gonna stay on the rails
we're not going into debt further and
you know you know that's what does it
that consistency for us was the down so
when you were going through Financial
Peace University what was the thing you
saw or experienced that made you believe
you could do this I I was always the one
that would do pay our bills every month
and we I knew we had all this debt we
kept getting you know better jobs
promotions but it still felt like we
were just getting more and more broke
just under the weight of all of our debt
and so we talked to different financial
planners and they just kind of took our
money and we weren't any better better
off so when I went to Financial Peace
University my expectations were a little
bit low I thought I'd kind of tried
everything and just when you're just
talking about like the Gazelle momentum
and just the process and it just made so
much sense and I just got so excited I
came home and I told Brian I want to do
this babe I think I want to sell my car
you know anything to get this debt down
and Brian loves his cars and so he was
like no we know
you can't go back to that class it's a
cold yeah and then the next day on his
own he listened to the podcast and he
heard you tell another guy asking
similar things you know boys like their
toys and men sacrifice to take care of
their families oh yeah he came to me and
said babe I think we should keep your
car install mine and we did Wow smack
down right there oh wow Oh Oh sometimes
I do that accidentally but there you go
in this case it worked out wonderfully
Wow very very cool well good for you I
mean what a great step up because I mean
I'm a car guy too and to dump a car is
it's a tough decision yeah
but the good news is there's cars
everywhere you can get another one
that's when you get a little money and
get better ones so that's what Melissa
explained to me yeah this is not a
permanent sacrifice yes no saying drive
a hoopty for 40 years were saying for
four years clean up the medicine yes
these kids on the right track and
everything very very cool well
congratulations you guys what was the
hardest part for you all you know I
think for me the hardest part was like I
said initially was that consistency in
it's not like we went on a budget
it was more like a lifestyle change so
we stopped going out to dinner we
stopped using credit cards we stopped
going on vacations that we couldn't
afford we actually lived below our means
which was you know something new for
both of us shocking yeah absolutely so
you know it was kind of hard in the
initially to give up that stuff but like
I said after we did it after we saw some
of the fruits of our labor
after that ball started rolling you know
we just got really excited about it and
you know kind of tightened up even more
you know very cool yeah when you see
some progress you you sacrifice even it
increases the intensity absolutely and
it changes things that's very neat well
congratulations you guys it's an honor
to have you with us all week at entree
leadership and thanks for coming in from
that all the way from California all
right
it's Brian and Melissa San Jose
California a hundred and twenty-five
thousand dollars paid off in four years
making eighty to once
60 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream 3
and the crowd goes wild
I love it I love it I love it how fun is
this hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind